les élites déphasé la technocratie le
pouvoir sous ses divorces sous ses
diverses formes et bien et et c'est en
quelque sorte d'empêcher l'émergence de
cet être ensemble fondamentale qui de
mon point de vue va revenir
être avec l'autre solidarité générosité
partage des boissons partage du sexe et
tout à l'avenant
alors moi je pense que ça il faudra voir
vous savez moi je je je
moi j'ai été préservés j'ai eu des amis
chers malheureusement qui sont morts et
qui sont atteints donc on ne peut pas
parler de cela comme ça d'une manière
légère mais il faudra voir si ce virus
continue à se mériter moi je suis pas
médecin je sais pas du tout de ma
compétence en sais rien mais par contre
ce que je peux dire d'un point de vue
social je n'ose pas dire sociologique
mais d'un point de vue social c'est
qu'il ya ce désir de l'autre de rentrer
en contact avec l'autre et que cela la
technocratie ne pourra pas le freiner
alors ces drones ces police et cetera
mais tout cela ne représente en quelque
sorte que la dictature douce de la
technocratie et de la bureaucratie
c'est une dictature il faut savoir le
dire les combats d'arrière-garde sont
les plus sanglants les plus violents les
plus méchants mais à mon sens le propre
d'un combat d'arrière-garde c'est qu'il
est perdu est de mon point de vue la
puissance populaire prendra le pas sur
le pouvoir institutionnel une forme de
sensibilité anarchisante qui est la
mienne l'anarchie c'est l'ordre sans
l'état il ya un ordonnancement des
choses qui va se faire encore une voix
et le fait d'être ensemble de partager
des trains amitié en amour avec l'autre
j'ai bien dit le mot de match et l'air
hors d'eau à maurice et ses 7 hors d'eau
à maurice qui est inéluctable c'est ça
la postmodernité c'est cet or docmorris
que la modernité avait nié ou daigné ses
sept hors d'eau à maurice qui va
triompher
à
[Musique]